[Music]
unit 2 is the backstage area still
secure
this is where all the training pays off
pardon me terribly sorry not a problem
keep your eyes open boys
waiting to communicate
[Music]
wolf is in position
piranha y'all penguin student
affirmative i'm a clean mean donkey
stealing machine what's going on guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
here let me help you
are you okay ma'am
oh my gracious yes
i may be dizzy like i'm alive thanks to
you
thank you dear
you're such a good boy
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna put you guys away for so long
your fleas will have fleas
[Applause]
you want some cake you seem a little
angry
drop that thing out of my face before
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah
we may be bad but we're so good at it
hey look it's a cat stuck in a tree
it doesn't get much simpler than that
now what in this scenario would give you
that good tingle eating it this is why i
always carry two pieces of bread with me
no i want you to
smack it
stab it saute it sing to it save it i
want you to set this up so obviously i
want you to save it all right
[Music]
i gave you an opportunity a chance to
show the world that you're more than
just a scary stereotype but
you're too proud or too gutless to take
advantage of it gutless i'm gutless
i'm sorry have we met i'm the villain of
every story guilty until proven innocent
even if by some miracle we did change
who's gonna believe us huh
of course you wouldn't know anything
about that with your little miss perfect
power suits
is that so
wait a second what did
how did you a wolf and a fox are not so
different
maybe they will believe you maybe they
won't but it doesn't matter
don't do it for them do it for you
this is a chance to write your own story
to find a better life for you and your
friends
come on what have you got to lose i
don't know my dignity
yeah well
that ship has already sailed
the bad guys is really cool
it's crime time baby it's slightly
dangerous it's witty and it's quick a
little crazy crazy you finally speaking
my language chico
we're the villains of every story the
animals are scared of
they're the best at being bad they're
the best criminals so long suckers
if you want to stay out of jail you need
to go good it's definitely a struggle
for them it's a cat stuck in a tree
i want you to
smack it
stab it saute think to it save it i want
you to say that's so obvious i want you
to save it oh
right
the cast is phenomenal insane everybody
really brings in their personality to
the characters and really shapes them
it's a real stretch cranky inflated
sense of self
yeah i had to really uh work on that at
home this is gonna taste extra sweet
nope
sucker does it i teach you to share
totally worth it
the action and the drama you're going to
laugh out loud
i'm having a baby
there's a lot of heartfelt stuff going
on too
you think you see an animation you think
[Music]
what happened did we blow up is this
heaven
when you go to cinema i don't really
want to know what i'm getting before i
see the movie i want something to be a
surprise
[Music]
and that's kind of what drew me to bad
guys i mean the way i always explain the
movie is i'm like it's like an animated
talentino movie that the family can
actually watch together
i want something that is not your
classical score but wanted a mix of jazz
and funk and rock
the sound of this film was always
something that both hearkened back to
classic heist movies of the 60s and 70s
and it had a different feel so it was
its own thing so it means you can have a
lot of fun you can get really big
okay that was
great it was really able to craft a
score that supports different themes
different story lines these are the
cards we've been dealt so we might as
well play them
let's bounce
[Music]
one of my favorite score pieces is
probably one of the first ones you hear
which is meet the bad guys in the middle
of a car chase you meet every single
character this is the crew so you have
to score both a car chase
and introducing all these crazy new
people into your life
his vision for what the music would be
is incredibly fresh jackpot
yes and always keeping your toes tapping
[Music]
that was actually kind of beautiful
[Music]
the gala song is a big moment in the
film
hey i know you think you know me you
made your own conclusion because it was
really a moment where music is a core
part of the story
it's such a relentlessly feel good
moment in the film i just wanna get that
song that like you have to start dancing
too
[Music]
the music really makes up this film
well this just got a little weird
with the bad guys you just get this
crazy experience that's all i'm really
aiming for
what's going on hi sam hi richard
sazzy what's up anthony what's happening
are we in the virtual mix
hey mark stop yelling at me hey craig
what's up everybody yeah baby
[Music]
this is bad guys here we go
wolf turns on the tv we hear breaking
news tiffany channel 6 action news the
bad guys have struck again all right
guys guys guys stop we're on tv we all
know how dastardly the bad guys are you
bet we are but what could be more
positive than the annual good samaritan
awards who's up for another job
a big one museum of fine art quick shot
of the bad guys infiltrate the party in
disguise as they waltz inside a stretch
limo pulls up and we reveal professor
marmalade this year's recipient of the
golden dolphin most annoying good guy on
the planet in the past year you've
stopped wars fed the hungry and saved
countless pandas some have described
your goodness as second only to mother
teresa oh tiffany it's not a competition
and if it were it would really be more
of a tie
motion sensing lasers can attract wolf
and snakes every movement they're
trapped can you give me five minutes
please we don't have five minutes that's
webs the curtain's going up any minute
tarantula's furiously hacking to no
avail it's not letting me in did you try
rebooting you probably need to download
a driver oh you guys fixed it really wow
and now the moment we've all been
waiting for the police cheat unlocks
security room door she's about to enter
when excuse me
is this the lady drift hold it what what
on stage the curtain rises to reveal the
golden dolphin is gone please do not
panic nice work now let's make like a
wolf and get the pack out of here ah
wordplay
i don't get it the partygoers see him oh
my god it's the bad guys they stole the
golden dolphin come on you can't prove
that
we're out of here so like suckers wolf
takes out the grappling hook gun it
shoots you towards the ceiling but
instead of carrying the guys to safety
shrimp
the cable tears his pants off well that
just got weird
amazing that was so good this is a
really good movie there's a bunch of
other people in it besides me insane
yeah right
that was amazing great job very fun you
want to run it one more time yeah let's
do the whole screen can you talk on the
phone for hours at a time please let's
have a premiere party well i'll come
over to your house
we gotta hang out
all right guys everyone call me in 10
minutes
okay mr snake i'm going to give you a
push pop great push pop just for me no
to share
why well on a fundamental level it's
about putting someone else's needs a
head of your own
oh no no way snake
ah
all righty all right this is gonna taste
extra sweet because i know how bad you
want it
[Music]
i like sharing it's yummy
totally worth it
well that's terrifying
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
remorseless sociopaths
oh stop you making me vlogs
we're the bad guys
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms
yes
miss tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
what's up papa
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it
we're out of here so long suckers
well this just got a little weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic wolf you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would smack it
stab it
we're more than just scary villains they
love us you're such a good boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is going to taste extra sweet
nope
sucker
i'll teach you the
totally worth it
[Music]
you